ce qui a le plus marqué les
téléspectateurs il ya soir c'est une
histoire entre eric et claudine qui a
atteint un point de non retour
je vais vous raconter notre histoire si
vous n'avez pas subi de ce couple qui a
déchaîné les passions
aujourd'hui alors joly avait johnny et
laeticia ma chance et eric des quotas
tout semblait avoir bien démarré entre
les deux tourtereaux puisque dès le
départ il sombre et très proches l'un de
l'autre
on sentait qu'il y avait un crush crush
deux roues à tel point
on a cru vraiment à une bonne histoire
d'amour regarde dit redouter temps de
finir sa vie sans personne qu'il avait
décidé de se sauver de cette fatalité
en s'inscrivant à l'émission une
opération de la dernière chance comme il
la qualifie lui même et dont eric a
découvert qu'elle repose sur l'unique
femme à lui avoir écrit c'est un peu
tendu mais on le sait une seule peut
suffire alors pourvu que ce soit la
bonne
moi j'ai l'impression que depuis
longtemps on dirait qu'on s'entend bien
et petit bois avec le dinh à la ferme
est longtemps oui tous le sont vos jours
et on a pensé trop longtemps tout seul
font qu'on rattrape du temps
et toi tu veux pour reste de ta vie bah
ouais
la rivale et parce que je vous raconter
toute l'histoire
restons famille vous d'aller voir la
tuera connaît tous et concevoir les
riquet konin là ça démarre bien
une belle histoire eric et claudine
alors faut savoir que c'est la seule
personne qui a écrit eric il a reçu
qu'une seule lettre
voilà et c'est claudine et la bim sa
vraiment du goût d'y croire ce match ça
match en match et directement entre eux
après vous parle du après vous avez un
truc en montre alors après je suis
raconter toute l'histoire puisque après
ce rendez-vous réussi
claude il a donc été invités à passer
quelques jours à la ferme d'eric une
première journée dont claudine se
souviendra
j'en avais la chair de poule rien tom
daschle j'espère s'arrête à la
boulangerie gâteau j'en mange plus là je
me force à pu manger est un peu grosse
je tiens mon look ça c'est un truc moi
la télé jour dans la journée jamais été
à fond plutôt populo réputé les jeux
peut en passer ta télé sur belle ttc
mois suivant
et oui alors forcément après cette
journée catastrophique
claudine pour une décision radicale elle
décide de quitter la ferme
c'est le moment fort de cette saison
christine elle prend ses cliques et ses
claques qui sont que claquent et elle
par une foutue t il je me dis va
peut-être se retourner quand même
discuté au mot la télé je mange je
regarde 1 télé c'est une habitude tu
fais quand même des petits sais c'est
pas ça c'est pas des gros efforts je
pense quand même au rap et au pire tu as
fait ton nom ton hier soir moi ça m'a
annoncé tu vois c'est pour ça il faut
jouer notre dame que je vous ai ras le
bol de ces dernières choses que j'avais
trouvé la femme de ma vie et maintenant
tout ça vous ne connaîtrez lyon
[Musique]
allez bisous
moi claudine la peau mate et de la fed
roman wick any person and aussi j'ai eu
clairement le coeur brisé
sur cette séquence et je vous jure que
j'ai failli avoir ma larme lama larme à
l'oeil
parce que je me dis ils sont en train de
se rater pour pas grand chose finit pas
besoin en bain de monsieur ça fait des
années si grave qu'il a était
célibataire et quand on est célibataire
autant de temps on a des choses à
apprendre
il faut compter sur claude est mauvais
pour lui apprendre et les choses un
centime pour moi elle a été trop dur
eddine al her a dû lui laisser une
deuxième chance parce que ce monsieur il
est maladroit il est tout ce que vous
voulez mais ça se voit qu'il a beaucoup
de choses à donner et qu'il étendrait
son annonce j'ai regardé parce que je
regarde ma copine carrière bien sûr j'ai
regardé hier soir et franchement je
crois que lui vous avez raison il lui
rate vraiment quelque chose il rate
cette dame elle doit remercier
aujourd'hui encore la télévision parce
que grâce à la télévision est riche
l'appel de vie
[Rires]
kelly elle prend toujours comme
d'habitude des choses à l'envers c'est
parce qu'il a été célibataire qu'il a
des mauvaises habitudes sais pas si les
demoiselles titre qu'il est toujours
célibataire et je le dis d'autant plus
facilement que mon grand père était
paysan mais c'est parce qu'ils sont
isolés de campagne qui sont célibataires
c'est souvent parce qu'ils sont taiseux
gilles soit un peu russe
ils ont des mauvaises manières il
s'intéresse mais non ils s'intéressent
pas et il avait une chance inouïe il l'a
pas saisie et bien c'est parce que la
preuve c'est que pendant toutes les
aventures il se demande la seule chose
qui les préoccupe c'est laquelle je vais
ce gir là qu'échouait choisir alors ils
s'adressent pas savoir si ils plaisent à
la caisse de choisir laquelle choisir et
se demande pas s'il plaît à personne
mais hé ben isabelle moi je suis
d'accord avec fini voilà effectivement
quelqu'un là comme ce qui se met à table
exactement dans la position où il se met
depuis 30 ans et elle est la fille comme
ça c'est bien beau mais je n'aurais pu
être patients jeunes ont pris l'habitude
ni celle ci ait du mal je trouve une
fois de plus sur les gens biwetz et un
beauf étonnement c'est pas bon c'est un
monsieur qui est seul depuis x temps et
qui effectivement ne sait plus vivre à
l'intrigué
c'est tout simplement pour moi dans
l'émission un mufle et j'ai trouvé la
scène extrêmement choquant pour l'image
de la femme
voilà bien fait partir la manière je lui
parle d'un c'est choquant moi ça marche
bien pour elle
je vous dis même je voulais toujours
dans les extrêmes mais bon non
traumatisée elle a bien su se défendre
non moi je vous donne le fond de ma
pensée c'est quand ça ne m'a gêné choqué
ouais mais août et durera le pardon mais
c'est l'émission qui est à gerber et
c'est ça qui m'a choqué parce que oui
lui peut-être que ça un vieux garçon
qu'il est bourru qui les voilà qu'il est
insupportable je les murs comme dit
comme dit gilles mais en fait nous on
est spectateur de leur histoire d'amour
mais nous on sait banlieue de juger avec
mépris et condescendance de savoir si ce
pauvre monsieur il aime bien où il est
mal où il aime comme il faut oui là les
bonnes manières bah oui mais excusez moi
je trouve ça dégueulasse et je te
rappelle qu'il est volontaire
ben oui mais moi je n'aime pas assisté à
ça c'est à dire qu'il ait hocine à
l'instrumentaliser et d'ailleurs quand
on regarde même nom se marre merci oui
bah oui mon père oui elle est
dégueulasse mais bien sûr mais bien sûr
tout le monde sait ça sur le compte
justement de la tendresse passé on
utilise ce pauvre maire jean leblanc ne
jugeant pas dire qu'à ce stade il n'y a
pas une caricature il peut pas mettre un
tee shirt comme ça les gens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mes côtés je me sens vraiment ce sont
des gens qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude à la période de deux à dix
bien sûr j'ai 11 ans ça veut dire que ce
monsieur et 80 du thon tee shirts très
bien ce qu'ils font en six matches et
rapporter à la maison je suis comme ça
mais ce n'est pas emballé l'agression je
peux pas y retourner deux autres
candidats gays
[Rires]